the city of kabul has experienced so
much upheaval for decades and this is
another change to get used to and one
that's far from easy
the situation for now is not clear no
one can say what will happen all the
people are just lost and confused
in the space of one traumatic day life
on the streets feels completely
different this is one of the most
obvious signs of the transformation
that's taken place here literally
overnight the whole of the center of
kabul is protected by these fortified
checkpoints concrete blocks barriers
normally guards carrying automatic
weapons and armored humvees with heavy
machine guns on this morning
nothing
people have been getting used to the
novelty of a new force in charge the
subject of intense curiosity as taliban
take up checkpoint duties on the roads
whoever used to fear us they've now seen
the mujahideen and that we are from the
soil and we don't want afghanistan to be
destroyed
but there's widespread nervousness about
what this new taliban rule will look
like
many businesses and shops remain closed
though there are signs of life returning
to normal
if there's peace then everyone will
benefit the businesses the workers
there are deep-rooted fears about the
erosion of basic rights in particular
for women and girls despite assurances
from the taliban
and about a return to cruel punishments
for certain crimes but many still
remember life under the previous taliban
government being at least crime free for
the most part
everybody will be safe nobody's kid will
be kidnapped again
with the sudden collapse of the afghan
government the people of kabul and their
new leaders have been thrown together
faster than any had expected
now together they're feeling their way
forward into their new reality
so rob when you're out there on the
streets of kabul it must feel almost
quite surreal
it is rather strange especially this was
the first day if you like of this new
reality the first full day of taliban
control and you saw it on the faces of
people coming out kabul residents monday
morning seeing these taliban some of
them for the first time uh some of the
older residents of course will remember
their rule uh from previously from the
mid 90s through till 2000 2001 many
people having of course very bad
memories and very bad experiences of
that time the taliban of course are
insisting this is a different type
of of rule now they will be a different
type of taliban more sensitive etc but
uh there it remains to be seen
especially in kabul if they will meet
those words with actions if they'll live
up to that and of course there is far
more scrutiny now uh 20 years later
because of uh communications and
technology the whole world is watching
and the whole world of course will
remember what uh what afghanistan went
through before 2001 and some of the
horrors so they are very much under
scrutiny and you do get a sense of that
that they do sense do feel as though the
world is watching and as to those scenes
from the airport rob is anyone actually
in charge of the airport because it's
it's a couple of hours since people were
trying to get onto or literally hang on
to those aircraft
there is a certain amount of order if
you like uh but there there are two
lines that are separated by this chaos
in the middle let me explain if you have
outside the terminal now you have a
taliban cordon uh sold armed taliban
keeping people away from the terminal
there's still a big pressure a lot of
people would still like to get in there
in fact we do hear occasionally the odd
burst of gunfire we know that taliban
soldiers and also u.s soldiers it seems
have been using weapons mainly hope
mainly to scare away uh people to to
force them back uh at gunpoint you also
have the u.s defensive line inside the
tournament inside
we're going live to the united nations
in new york because this special meeting
on afghanistan has just kicked off it
was scheduled to take place in about 10
minutes from now
delegates members and ambassadors are in
the chamber slightly earlier let's
listen in to what's being said
generation of young afghan women and
girls boys and men
at this grave hour i urge all parties
especially the taliban
to exercise utmost restraint to protect
lives and to ensure that humanitarian
needs can be met
conflict
has forced hundreds of thousands from
their homes
the capital city has seen a huge influx
of internally displaced persons from
provinces around the country
where they felt insecure or fled during
fighting
i remind all parties of their obligation
to protect civilians
and i call on all parties to provide
humanitarians with unimpeded access to
deliver timely and life-saving services
and aid
and i also urge all countries to be
willing to receive afghan refugees
and refrain from any deportations
mr president
now is the time to stand as one
the international community must be
united
and utilize all available instruments to
ensure the following
first
we must speak with one voice to uphold
human rights in afghanistan
i call upon the taliban and all parties
to respect and protect international
humanitarian law
and the rights and freedoms of all
persons
we are receiving chilling reports of
severe restrictions on human rights
throughout the country
and i am particularly concerned by
accounts of mounting human rights
violations against the women and girls
of afghanistan who fear a return to the
darkest days
it is essential that the hard-won rights
of afghan women and girls are protected
they are looking to the international
community for support
the same international community that
assured them that opportunities would be
expanded education would be guaranteed
freedoms would be spread and rights
would be secured
second the international community must
unite to make sure that afghanistan is
never again used as a platform or safe
haven for terrorist organizations
i appeal to the security council and the
international community as a whole
to stand together to work together and
act together
and use all tools at its disposal to
suppress the global terrorist threat in
afghanistan
and to guarantee that basic human rights
will be respected
regardless of world's power
these two fundamental principles in
which our world has such a deep and
abiding interest must be upheld
mr president
the united nations is committed to
supporting afghans
we continue to have staff and offices in
areas that have come under taliban
control
i am relieved to report that in large
measure
our personnel and premises have been
respected
we urge the taliban to continue to do so
and to honor the integrity and inferior
inviolability of diplomatic envoys and
premises
the mediterranean crisis in afghanistan
affects 18 million people
fully half of the country's population
it is vital that basic services continue
to be provided
in a statement issued yesterday
the taliban said that they would work
with existing institutions it is crucial
that civil servant salaries continue to
be paid infrastructure is maintained
airports are reopened and health and
education services continue
the united nations presence will adapt
to the security situation
but above all we will stay and deliver
in support of the afghan people in their
hour of need
looking ahead i call for an immediate
end to violence for the rights of all
afghans to be respected
and for afghanistan to comply with all
international agreements to which it is
a party
mr president afghans are a proud people
with a rich cultural heritage
they have known generations of war and
hardship
they deserve our full support
the following days will be pivotal the
world is watching
we cannot and must not abandon the
people of afghanistan and i thank you
i thank the secretary general for his
briefing
i now give the floor to the
representative afghanistan you have the
floor please
your excellency the president
excellency
mr secretary general excellencies ladies
and gentlemen good morning
thank you mr president for this
opportunity to speak at yet another
council meeting on the situation in
afghanistan and for india's leadership
of the council during this critical
period
we welcome the convening of this
emergency session of the security
council on the situation in afghanistan
and thank all the council members
particularly estonia and norway a
scorpion holder of afghanistan for their
role in organizing this session
mr president
today i'm speaking on behalf of millions
of people in afghanistan
whose fate hangs in the balance and are
faced with an extremely uncertain future
i'm speaking for millions of affluent
girls and women who are about to lose
their freedom to go to school to work
and to participate in the political
economic and social life of the country
i'm speaking for thousands of human
rights defenders journalists academics
civil servants and former security
personnel whose lives are at risk for
defending human rights and democracy
i'm speaking for thousands of internally
displaced people who are desperately in
need of shelter food and protection in
kabul and other places
as you're witnessing yourself the
situation in kabul a city of about 6
million people is extremely worrying to
say the least
you have seen chaotic scenes at the
kabul international airport as desperate
citizens are trying to leave the country
mr president
we are extremely concerned about
taliban's not honoring their promises
and commitments made in their statements
at doha and at other international fora
we've witnessed time and again how
taliban have broken their promises and
commitments in the past
we have seen gruesome images of
taliban's mass executions of military
personnel and target killings of
civilians in kandahar and other big
cities
mr president
we cannot allow this to happen in kabul
which has been the last refuge for many
people escaping violence and taliban's
revenge attacks
kabul residents are reporting the
taliban have already started
house-to-house searches in some
neighborhoods registering names and
looking for people in their target list
there are already reports of target
killings and looting in the city
kabul residents are living in absolute
fear right now
mr president
there is no time for blame game anymore
we have an opportunity to prevent
further violence prevent afghanistan
descending into a civil war and becoming
a pariah state
therefore the security council
and the u.n secretary general should use
every means at its disposal to call for
an immediate secession of violence and
respect for human rights and
international humanitarian law
call on the taliban to fully respect the
general amnesty offered by them cease
target killing and revenge attacks and
abide by international humanitarian laws
urge that no public institutions and
service delivery infrastructure be
demolished including works of arts in
museums and media institutions
stress that anyone violating human
rights of afghan citizen and
international humanitarian law will be
held accountable
urgently establish a humanitarian
corridor for the evacuation of those at
risk of taliban's retributions and
attacks
call on neighboring countries of
afghanistan to open their borders and
facilitate exit of people trying to
escape an entry of goods for
humanitarian relief and operations
call for the immediate establishment of
an inclusive and representative
transitional government that includes
all ethnic groups and women
representatives which can lead to a
dignified and lasting solution to the
conflict bring peace and preserve the
gains of the last 20 years especially
for women and girls
stress
that the council and the united nations
will not recognize any administration
that achieves power through force or any
government that is not inclusive and
representative of its diversity
of the country
unequivocally state that it does not
recognize the restoration of the islamic
emirate as reinformed in previous
council statements and agreements
establish international guarantees for
the implementation of a future political
agreement
and finally mobilize urgent humanitarian
assistance for the 18 million people of
afghanistan particularly those displaced
by current conflict
the u.n humanitarian appeal at 1.3
billion dollars remain 40 percent funded
we urge the international community to
meet the remainder of this life-saving
appeal to provide critical aid to all
internally displaced people
at the end i would like to thank the
united nations and many other
international organizations who are on
the ground providing life-saving
humanitarian support and monitoring
human rights on the ground thank you mr
president
i thank the representative afghanistan
for a statement
i will now give the floor to those
council members who wish to make
statements
i give the floor to the representative
of estonia you have the flow please
thank you mr president
you're watching al jazeera live for you
there at the un building in new york we
heard there from antonio guterres she
was talking about respecting human
rights now it's the time to stand as one
we must be united he said but
significantly we heard from gulam
azekzai the afghan ambassador to the un
he said he was speaking on behalf of
millions of people speaking for women
girls journalists internally displaced
people he said we've seen how the
taliban have broken their promises in
the past sitting in
on that discussion watching it for us
from his usual vantage point is our
diplomatic editor james bayes james what
do you make of what we've heard so far
well i think what you heard from the
secretary general was deep concern from
the united nations two uh main areas
that they were looking at one was human
rights and one was the possibility of as
he describes it terrorist organizations
returning to afghanistan those are
clearly the major concerns of the un
which keeps its operation yunama on the
ground in afghanistan he says they are
staying but i can tell you the reality
right now is they are staying but locked
in their compounds because of the
security situation and the worries about
the security situation we'll need to
check in the coming hours where they're
going to start doing some of their
humanitarian work again i think also
important is what we heard then from the
afghan ambassador to the united nations
yes he is still the afghan ambassador to
the united nations even though he was
sent to new york in that job by a
government that no longer exists and i
think it's going to be interesting as we
hear the other speakers
to see whether some of the countries
start to nod towards recognizing the
taliban and certainly we're hearing that
coming out of moscow and beijing not a
formal recognition yet uh but uh the
idea that they'll be prepared to work
with the taliban so listen very
carefully uh in the next hour or so when
we have the speeches from the russian
and the chinese ambassador i think it
will also be interesting uh to hear from
some of the us's close allies in
afghanistan behind the scenes i can tell
you they are not saying good things
about what's happened they don't feel
they were properly consulted before
president biden made his announcement
that he was withdrawing the troops and
they don't think that this has been
handled in in
in a good way by the u.s the way that
they've they've handled the withdrawal
will we hear that publicly certainly i i
heard the irish ambassador on the way in
to use the word catastrophe so it'd be
interesting to see how some of those
allies respond 15 members of the
security council six of them at some
point had troops uh the u.s and five
others troops in afghanistan over the
last 20 years but james when the afghan
ambassador gulam izak zai was talking
about establishing a humanitarian
corridor and calling on afghan
afghanistan's neighbouring countries to
open their borders the reality is that
it's too early for that to happen yet
because we're still this is just
24 hours in effect since ashraf ghani
did a bunk and that border between
afghanistan and pakistan essentially is
sealed afghanistan needs pakistan
pakistan needs afghanistan but
afghanistan's a landlocked country and i
guess diplomats must understand why
islamabad is choosing to essentially as
i say keep that border closed the
chinese as well they have a very short
border that they share with afghanistan
but there are certain strategic issues
that beijing would be worried about when
it comes to what happens with those
border crossings
yeah i mean i i in in terms of people
crossing the border i don't think given
where the the the border with china is
um afghanistan looks a little bit like
this like a fist well the border with
china is at the very top there uh it's a
tiny border and a pretty mountainous
region but i think the places that
they're going to be major uh refugee
flows are potentially into pakistan and
iran and both countries have housed
millions of afghan refugees in the past
and i don't think will want to publicly
signal that they're opening the borders
and
have a humanitarian corridor in the way
the ambassador suggested because that
may lead to a major major uh
displacement of people across the
borders the un is worried that literally
millions of people might try uh to leave
afghanistan also worth noting that the
the afghan ambassador was still talking
about the idea of a representative
transitional government representing all
the different factions in afghanistan
and remember that's what they were
talking about in those talks in doha
that never got to an agreement well i
don't think there's any sign that the
taliban now are going back to that plan
the taliban have all of afghanistan
they're in total control and i don't
think they're going to give that up and
as far as mr ezekiel's continuation or
continuing role
at the united nations even if the
taliban correct me if i'm wrong here
james even if the taliban says he does
not speak for us he does not speak for
the country it's not actually down to
them is it that there is a body
contained within the united nations that
decides this guy is the ambassador for
that country even if that country in
quotes doesn't exist in the form that it
existed when he was appointed to the
position
there is a procedure and it's likely to
be a contentious procedure i think you
need to see who the key players are on
the security council and among the
general membership of the united nations
which ones start to recognize the
taliban and then ultimately it will go
to the general assembly but the first
body that looks at it is something
called the credentials committee of the
general assembly and i think that that's
normally doesn't do very much work it
doesn't really need to do very much work
but on this occasion um with the next
general assembly starting next month i
think they're going to have to look at
the credentials of afghanistan and the
current ambassador but actually at the
same time worth reminding you there's a
big row going on and dispute about the
ambassador from myanmar so potentially
we could have two two representations
change was it significant for you james
when the afghan ambassador was saying no
time for the blame game i mean that that
does not chime at all with those people
who are criticizing the biden
administration right now
no and it doesn't i don't think chime
with a lot of what i'm hearing from um
those that were part of the ghani
administration now some of those are
blaming the us
and some of them are blaming president
ghani himself who clearly was despised
by many in afghanistan including members
of his own cabinet and some of his inner
circle as an ineffective leader uh at
the end uh it is interesting that the
speech didn't really take a political
tone i think that's because this afghan
ambassador um now in a job that
representing a government that doesn't
exist has only been in the job um for uh
nearly a month he only presented his
credentials to the secretary general
taking up the job at the end of july
and his previous job was as a u.n
official so i think it was a somewhat
measured um speech from him not a
political speech
just because of the background of the
man
we're currently waiting on the norwegian
delegation the norwegian ambassador
wrapping up because we're anticipating
the us ambassador is next james as far
as sort of international diplomatic
circles are concerned
critics of the biden administration are
saying this was or is
playing out in real time day to day week
to week now a colossal foreign policy
blunder
it may damage
mightn't it
the us standing internationally as a
force for good diplomatically but will
it damage the biden administration in
your opinion james because when one
talks to american colleagues american
friends or just engages with the debate
in america americans are so weary of
going to other people's wars and
literally chucking in
gazillions of us dollars to fund it
getting involved in nation building and
then pulling out anyway americans have
had enough of this
well certainly it will damage i think
the us's credibility and power and
prestige in the world
concerning its allies and its
adversaries but i think you might be
right on the point about americans not
caring about afghanistan and not wanting
to be in afghanistan but then again
remember the power of pictures
remember those chaotic scenes that we've
seen in recent hours out of kabul
airport those scenes are are desperate
for all of us but they also i suspect
show a humiliation of the us the way
it's had to leave and that will play out
on every american's tv screens in the
coming hours let's see what the us have
to say about this because the u.s
ambassador peter is about to speak
okay james we'll talk to you in a minute
thank you so much thank you mr president
secretary general guterres thank you for
your sobering briefing and for your
strong
statement
your role
along with your personal envoy john or
no and special representative lyons and
her team on the ground
is especially vital now
and as we enter an uncertain and crucial
period that requires the international
community to speak with a clear and
unified voice
the united states deeply appreciates the
continued efforts of yanama and other
u.n actors on the ground in afghanistan
that are continuing to provide
life-saving assistance to afghans in
need
we also thank norway
and estonia for calling this meeting in
india for convening it given the events
of the past 72 hours and we welcome the
participation of afghanistan to this
meeting
over this past weekend members of the
international community joined together
to state unequivocally that every afghan
should be able to live in safety
security and dignity
we also called on all parties in
afghanistan to ensure safe departures
and the protection of human life and
property
today i want to reiterate re-emphasize
and reassert this call
civilian populations including
journalists and non-combatants must be
protected attacks against civilians or
civilian objects must stop and the human
rights and fundamental freedoms of all
afghan citizens especially women girls
and members of minority groups must be
respected
we also call on all parties to prevent
terrorism and we must all ensure
afghanistan cannot ever
ever again be a base for terrorism
we also call on the taliban to permit
humanitarian organizations to continue
their valuable work in afghanistan
in addition to the ongoing violence the
afghan people are suffering acutely from
the effects of covet 19 and drought
these urgent humanitarian needs must
remain top of mind for all of us in the
coming hours days and weeks
and beyond
humanitarian personnel and agencies must
have safe unhindered access to provide
life-saving assistance to the increasing
numbers of afghans in need
we are deeply concerned that right now
aid is not flowing to people in crisis
according to the world food program more
than 500 tons of aid are currently
sitting at border crossings taken over
by taliban forces
these aid deliveries must remain must
resume immediately and the world food
program must have immediate and
sustained safe passage to deliver this
much needed assistance
finally and critically all afghan
nationals and international citizens who
wish to depart must be allowed to do so
safely
president biden has made clear that any
action that put u.s personnel or our
mission at risk will be met with a swift
and strong military response
the united states promises to be
generous in resettling afghans in our
own country and i'm heartened by the
pledges we've seen from other nations to
do the same
we need to all do more and the time to
step up is now
we urge afghanistan's neighbors and
others in the region and beyond to give
refuge to be it temporary or permanent
to afghans attempting to flee
and together we must do everything we
can to help afghanistan to help afghans
who wish to leave and seek refuge
i will close where i began
the afghan people deserve to live in
safety security and dignity
we in the international community stand
ready to assist them thank you very much
speaker there at that special meeting of
the united nations the u.s ambassador
linda thomas greenfield minority groups
must be respected she said talking about
girls and women people suffering anyway
she was making the point from covid19
coronavirus and there's a bad drought in
certain areas
of afghanistan and now because a lot of
the borders have been sealed aid is not
getting to the people who need it the
people in crisis james bayes is our
diplomatic editor time to step up is now
she said james
what does that mean
i don't know what it means um it's
really not clear what the us will do
beyond what they're doing currently at
kabul airport uh because they have no
tools anymore the us is virtually out of
afghanistan the only
operation they have is that ongoing
operation at the airport clearly there
was a strong message i think to the
taliban about that ongoing operation
saying that any uh any interference with
them any attack on them would be met
with a swift and strong military
response but beyond that most of the
speech one of my colleagues said to me
was very very safe
she didn't there was no there were no
strong particularly strong words
emotional words she didn't describe the
scenes that have have
concerned us all so greatly in the last
48 hours particularly the chaos at kabul
airport where the u.s military are
supposed to be in control uh no no none
of that it was a very very safe speech
by the by the by the u.s ambassador no
passion some would argue argue perhaps
no compassion given given the scenes
we've been seeing
james many thanks james bayes our
diplomatic editor wrapping up the events
there at the united nations in new york
that meeting called so that all the
relevant delegates and ambassadors can
talk about what's going on in
afghanistan today and yesterday today
we've seen those scenes of absolute
chaos dangerous chaos
at the airport as people were so keen to
get out of the country literally hanging
on to the side of us military aircraft
and tony gutierrez saying we must
respect human rights now is the time to
stand as one